okay
members good evening
good evening and welcome to this meeting
on the development committee i will now
read out the emergency evacuation
announcement
should we be required to evacuate the
building would you please leave the
building via the entry doors to the hall
continue straight on go through the two
sets of double doors on the right hand
side of the car park which is the
assembly point please do not delay your
evacuations to collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so
by council staff
please note that the meeting will be
audio recorded please switch off mobiles
or turn them to silence
members there is a need to use
microphones during this meeting when i
invite you to speak please wait until
there is a microphone in front of you
before speaking as microphones are
needed for the hearing loop and for the
audio recording
please where possible is assist in path
sorry
please where pos
where possible assist in passing
microphones to each other and use the
hand gel and antibacterial wipes on the
tables if you do
touch the microphones
members voting will be done on a show of
hands
in line with the constitution
i will ask for a show of hands for and
then against recommendations
and we'll also ask for a show of hands
for those wishing to abstain from voting
thank you
agenda items one and two apologies for
absence and substitutes please
dave
council davis
um
who's he substituting for
but we have received apologies for
absence from councillor daniel fd
councillor adrienne's and councillor at
lisa newport
councillor dave sparing is substituting
for council daniel fd
councillor michael hoy is substituting
for councillor agenese and councillor
christine mason is substituting for
council lisa newport
agenda item
three non-op
members attending
council of newport councillor cheryl
rowe
councillor simon wooten and i've got
councillor um gadsden but i don't think
she's here is she
no no
okay thank you
agenda four meetings meet
agenda item four minutes of the meeting
held on the 23rd of
september are these
agreed members
thank you
to receive declarations of interest
counsellor newports he's not committing
dollars we don't need to
he doesn't
transparency
um items item number seven non-pecuniary
interest
as a tenant of the landowner
thank you
is there any others members
no thank you
agenda lighting
um
i think i'm also a tenant of
the um the landowner number item number
seven
thank you very much
any others members
look
agenda item six is the site of board
hall uh board hall lane hotly mike
shanks will present the officer's report
thank you mike
thank you
members will be recalling this site of
the former uh prison
located um back from the main road area
of hockley if you could jump to the
layout and please
members will recall um
sorry mike have you got your my sorry
mike have you got your mic on
how about that that's better can you
hear members everyone yeah thank you
um to recap this is the site of the
former uh majesty's prison forward hall
that members will be aware was given
planning permission to develop for 70
houses
the
application you have which you'll have
seen concerns a single issue of obscure
glazing to windows
members will recall that we granted
planning from the rather blanket
approach to obscure glaze first floor
side windows that they'd be obscure
glazed and fixed shut
and
i think somewhere in the course of the
construction the applicants
installed clear glaze windows
and you dealt with an application in
april of this year
where they tried to overcome your
concerns
but members were unhappy with the hinge
arrangement arguing that there could be
overlooking through those
so the application you have before you
concerns the buildings usefully coloured
red
on this plant they're the dark shaded
dwellings that you can see
in solid
color
on the plans here
and
these ones you'll see they open out onto
open spaces i don't know if members can
see the triangles
that you can see on each side here
if we zoom in a little bit we might see
some of them but i'm conscious we'd lose
the whole layout
and that's better thanks that that's
good you'll see that
what the applicants are now asking you
is for just this select group of
dwellings that are in the solid block
to be allowed to
retain the clear glazed opening windows
and their argument being
that the windows of concern overlook
onto open areas like we see here
less so for this one which i'll come on
to because there's three plots that
you'll see in the officer report that we
disagree with
if we could look at uh
two plan plot one please
the architects have usefully given us a
layout of the site and you see the
windows they'll keep the ones
blue make them obscure glaze but there's
clear glazing these two which
unfortunately it's inverted but these
look out here in the case of plot one we
say that's acceptable because it
overlooks the open space but if we jump
to three plan please
plot 11 is uh one of these two that were
off the mate sorry group of four off the
main group and you'll see that there's
two windows either side of the front
projection we're happy that the outward
facing windows
um can be retained obscured but clear
sorry
but the inner facing ones that overlook
this area here of privacy with some
advantage possibly have been able to
look into the buildings we're unhappy
about
and if we jump to the next
plan please
the reverse is true this is the end unit
which is a mirror the one we was just
looking at where this window is of
concern to officers which overlooks
through here
and if we then go to a plan please
how's that
yep
sounds good thank you
um
if we look at the
uh plan here this is outward facing but
at an angle so that the view twists out
this way which officers feel we can
accept but our concern is this window
here which overlooks the quiet areas the
rear garden spaces of that adjoining
group of dwellings
so the upshot is we can almost
recommend to you to support the
applicant with the exception
of the last three plots that i showed
you
and therefore
you have the capability to be able to
vary the applicant's
condition
instead of accepting
all the plots proposed
officers have adapted that condition to
accept the numbers of dwellings that
they're proposing with the exception
of the three plots that i've just
pointed out where there is still in
office is concerned that overlooking
problem
now as you've heard me probably say
before when we have these uh variations
of condition
it's actually a legal requirement that
although we're dealing with a single
issue for
just the obscure glazing windows
nice straightforward single issue
you're obliged as a planning authority
to review the whole decision notice and
reissue the consent
and that's in light of where conditions
have been discharged on the earlier
permissions granted
they're no longer necessary so all the
conditions actually get all out of
kilter and this is
one such where what was condition five
so the applicant has submitted the
application to very condition five
because of the dispensing of other
conditions no longer necessary and do
not need to be reimposed
this now becomes condition three
so we're recommending that you
revise condition what becomes condition
three
along the lines
um that i've explained that it it's
almost allowing all the plots that
they've said
but for the specified windows that
overlook uh that i pointed out
i'm hoping chairman that's clear so the
recommendation is approval subject to
the revised condition five which now
becomes condition three
thank you very much
um
that's the cheryl rowe
how are you
you're the board member have you got
anything
no no he's visiting members first
thank you
uh council sparring
members
oh sorry sorry is there any other
members
visiting members that me would like to
speak on this
swearing
thank you
um
the issue regarding the
level of being the height of 1.7 meters
has been
been met in both areas so yeah i can't
see anything that i can disagree with
with mike shanks's recommendation
chairman thank you very much
council david merrick
have you got anything being a world
member
thank you
councillor smith and then i'll speak out
for christine mason uh
thank you chairman um we've discussed
this item on a number of occasions
and slowly evolved a solution um the
application which mr strengths has
outlined
with the exceptions
also outlined
is a
in my opinion a fair um description of
of a good way forward so actually
chairman i'm happy to move this
application
have your second
thank you
we have a recommendation for approval
is everyone's amazing oh sorry mrs mason
have you got a microphone
so you're only speaking to the approval
now
i just want to
say that i've been involved in plans of
this and i know the amount of work that
the office is doing and the detailed
work that goes into it and i'd like to
just acknowledge the amount of work they
have done
and certainly i would have seconded or
moved reversal if it hadn't already been
done so um assuming that the conclusion
with those three plots are the exception
so
that's all i wanted to say thank you
madam chairman thank you very much
members we've had a recommendation for
approval can i or can you all
please raise your hands for approval
if you're
yeah
it's unanimous thank you members
members have you seen the addendums for
item seven and have you all read them
please
you don't need any no one needs any time
to read them thank you very much
so we'll move on to item seven
which is the landlord of the national
grid london road aurora
and it will be
i can't hear you mike sorry
members will be pleasant members will be
broadly familiar with this site the
uh a130 dual carriageway
through here dollyman's farm access into
there and old london road
a129 at the top here with a collection
of number of dwellings here our site
concerns this area that you see here
before we leave this plan
you'll see on the addendum that there's
a letter been received and some of the
details of the letter actually was quite
critical that they weren't notified that
particular resident
is about a third of a mile
from that point on this plane that the
chichester backs onto this field about
here somewhere on this scale and it's up
the corner if members remember where the
football fields are and the four
bungalows
so
the government's advice on consulting
residents is that we consult within four
metres of the site boundary
this area here and you see there's no
one
actually within that but we went further
some 26 residents in this facility we
consulted them plus a site notice but we
wouldn't have gone
as far away as as has been suggested
so i was just pointing that out
before we proceed
if we could
um go to the uh
two plan please
this isn't before you tonight this is a
previous application which concerned um
gas-fired uh emergency generators the
issue behind all this is that
particularly renewable energies
solar and wind it varies the amount of
input they can put into the grid
so we approved as a authority
a while back
an application to have this series of
gas-fired boilers that had a flick of a
switch putting it very simply
would be able to be called upon by the
national grid to put energy into the
network
when there was a a deficit
now the council approved this it's in
the green belt but there are reasons why
this had to be located here which one in
this case was the supply of gas but
other reasons
of connectivity to the grid just off
this plan there is a substation large
substation that serves the sub-region
and it's necessary for this kind of
facility whatever it might be
to get quick access at this point
also in an area where the grid has
capacity
and there's only two places out of some
168 choices both of which are in the
green belt where this could be done
if we could jump to
the next one please alongside the gas
fire that you've just left this is a
cross section of the gas fires you'll
see an apparatus here with chimneys on
but if we can jump to the battery
storage there was a company in battery
storage on
the adjoining parcel of land
i think that's probably for plan if
that's it yeah
we was just looking at a previous
approval for the gas-fired boilers this
is a previous approval for battery
storage now that's that's in the bank
that's been approved
if we can now go to five plan please
this is what's before you tonight
the applicants have decided against the
use of the emergency fire boilers
and are looking to provide
further battery storage the idea being
that the
renewable energies that are created
uh need somewhere to to be stored
you can't you can't hold it back very
well energy is either in
surplus or
under capacity so batteries are the
answer
where there's surplus generation to be
able to store them and call upon them
so what we have here is a different type
of arrangement where
all of this area now whereas batteries
were previously approved over here the
generators instead of
now proposed with with batteries i'm
hoping that's clear
as i said the considerations are the
site is in the green belt so there has
to be very special circumstances
somewhat unique circumstances
and in this case because there's only
two or so
areas where this could connect to
national grid that is almost a unique
but for one other circumstance
so officers felt that in the
terms of the critical infrastructure
that this provides to the power network
the capacity that would be needed
locally and in the sub-region
coupled with the fact that it's against
an existing power facility as a backdrop
we can't see that on this and i don't
think we've got any images of it but i'm
sure members will have seen from the
a130 the sort of architecture of the
substation this would sit alongside that
so if you take into account the the
visual harm which would have the
backdrop of us a similar looking type of
facility
plus the need the critical
infrastructure need for energy storage
and where it can access the network
officers
feel that that amounts to very special
circumstances
so the recommendation chairman is
approval
for the condition to the
subject to the conditions set out in the
report
thank you um counselor you paul have you
anything no thank you councillor stanley
any other visiting any other visit sorry
any other visiting members oh you have a
speaker
is that on yeah
five minutes you've got five minutes um
thank you madam chairman i went with
that long
um mike set out the scene um very
clearly i i was just going to um add two
points
can i excuse me so can i ask you who you
are yes sir my name is andrew troupe
so it's for the committee to know who
you are thank you that's right and i'm a
director of satire energy we
operate batteries and have done so for
three or four years now
um
probably three points just to quickly
make one is on on the need for these um
i'm sure you're all aware that
boris johnson has
further added to the urgency of
deployment renewables
so that
absolutely requires us to try and
balance out the system
increasingly so
and at the moment batteries are the best
way of doing it as it is absolutely
fundamental if we're going to continue
to try and decarbonize the electricity
system
mike's explained why this particular
location is
very well suited for it the second point
is the parish council had raised a point
about the access and could we use
national grid access
and i'm sort of apologizing for that
because we can't um we would have done
it we could have done we've got a we've
got a consent now for an alternative
access but just to
say to members it's it's it should not
be an issue hey we've got consent for it
anyway but the amount of traffic that
this will
require once it's built is incredibly
low i mean there may be days when
nothing turns up at all and maybe a day
when two two white vans turn up so
there's no traffic generated from this
facility
effectively the other the third thing to
say the final thing just to say was was
on on decommissioning because i think
that was another point the parish
council raised
or one of the members might have raised
so we we have to put in place an
insurance policy which kicks in at year
10 on this on this arrangement
where we have to set aside
hundreds of thousands of pounds
effectively to ensure that it is
decommissioned
right now it is it is true to say that
the
the recycling of commercial scale
batteries
is has still to be sorted out it's
happening in norway it's happening in
belgium but all commercial scale
mattress now are generally repurposed on
solar farms but this is a lease here
which will last for probably 25 years so
it is a long way off
um and but that is all covered through
an insurance policy thank you madam
chair thank you
this is your members um mr councillor
newport no any other visiting members
that would like to speak on this
thank you
councillor stanley
thank you
there's two things that do concern me
um
special circumstances
special circumstances on the green belt
green belt
doesn't indicate that
putting batteries on there
is a good idea
the idea of the green belt is to keep it
green belt for the public to walk across
and
to associate themselves with a green
field
putting batteries on is not quite the
same thing
the batteries are in place of the
generating station that's there or was
was going to be there
so the batteries need to be charged up
from the supply
that's generated across the other side
of the road
they're not generating any electricity
so therefore
they're not they're not regenerative
they're not they only supply what they
take out so they'll supply it back into
the grid
so there's nothing being generated it's
not reusable it's not being generated so
reusable in the way of a wind farm or
solar energy and that sort of thing
is
reusable energy but the reusable energy
is coming out of the grid and therefore
why do we need batteries
the other course that i'm looking at
is there's no statement
of fireproof
fireproofing the sites should anything
go wrong we've already had a problem
with
michelin's farm in the way of
uh
fire on the tyres that were set alive
how do we know is there any
fact
that's
used usable to the committee that
this
this cannot happen in this
battery
container
there's nothing on there that
i haven't read anything on on the on the
information
so i'd like to ask the
uh officers has that been considered in
the way of and do we have actually a
fire service that can take control of
that site should that happen
i'd like to ask the officers if we've
got anything in that form
of
protection thank you
thank you
straight you've come back on the
question please
thank you chairman i mean
the simple answer on the fire question
is no we don't we don't have anything
i think sometimes we have to be careful
that
planning
sort of gives an opportunity for
everybody to express worries and
concerns and there are other agencies
working away to make things safe that
have no public involvement
and we have to be careful that planning
doesn't try to do
what perhaps other
licensing authorities and things have to
when you think of the mobile phone
systems
they they go through a certain safety
precautions before they are allowed to
hit the market
so you know i would have thought members
can be assured i take the point about
the michigan's farm situation which was
burning of waste
but
you know perhaps they do what they can
to make sure things don't catch fire but
i think you can never 100 avoid it
perhaps but this is a low key
activity i take the point that there
will be electricity stored on the site
and the shortages you know short
circuits and things that may be possible
i don't know it's not my field
but
[Music]
you know normally when equipment is
available it's already gone through
various tests that before it can be used
that's all i could offer members on that
point
and if i may just um say about the
supply issue
the idea of these batteries is that say
out in the north sea or somewhere
they're going to be generating power by
wind or there's going to be solar farms
that power comes into a network
but unlike unlike a product that you
might make in a factory and you park it
in a warehouse or on open storage or
something until it's required
you can't do that with power
you the the guys on the national grid
sort of operate a needle between things
remember the old jokes they used to say
about when eastenders finished on a
cliffhanger so everybody made a cup of
tea and the needle shot up they had to
call on nuclear power station or
something to
to compensate it but they they haven't
got so much of that now with the absence
of coal fired and things that they used
to have so what they're trying to do is
to
create batteries
whereby the renewable energy that's
pumping away during perhaps a windy
weather or a sunny day
can come into the grid be stored in
these batteries
and then when we get a moment when we
need some supply they can activate the
batteries and take take that out
that's about as
simple as my explanation is chairman but
i think members are right that there
isn't power generation as such but it's
all about power storage
and when we we talk in the green belt
about very special circumstances members
are right the idea is that
the
open spaces should be kept free of
building uh perhaps don't say it's
necessarily for public access
is perhaps for the identity of areas to
segregate say areas from benfleet from
raleigh from other areas to keep an
identity and for the
the
meaningfulness of openness but
if development has a very special
justification i used the term earlier
somewhat unique
and if it has to be there for whatever
reason i used to use the example of a
lighthouse you know it saves lives etc
it might be that you need a lighthouse
on a certain part of the coast these
days they're done remotely by ships and
things so it's an out-of-date example
but this facility can only connect in
very few places where there is capacity
in the network to take the connection
and the applicants of survey they tell
me about 168 sites
and only two fit the
requirements and they both happen to be
in the green belt
so
the network requires this storage
capacity
and
to be delivered it's gonna harm the
green belt somewhere now we've given way
to the fact that it's alongside an
existing facility so visually yes there
will be an increased footprint of
electrical apparatus
but it should be in our view the least
damaging and hence why we're
recommending to you the way we are thank
you chairman thank you very much uh
chairman may i'll reply to that please
because you had your sorry you paid for
five minutes so i didn't think i had
five minutes yeah we had unfortunately
it goes so quick
otherwise could i just reply to that
please well we've got other people
watching
being in the industry
foreign we have other we've got two
other members that need to speak on this
please
one is right now you can pull faces but
that is the way that um this committee
is going to be run you've got other
members that need to speak there's
councillor christine mason and
councillor
oh
he's making and councillor hawaii yes so
that's that'll be
council smith councillor christie mason
and
councillor hoy and councillor spelling
that's the order that they've been put
down on
thank you uh you first then councillor
thank you um
notwithstanding the
permissions that are already in place
i couldn't disagree more with councillor
stanley on this occasion in all the
years that i've been involved in
planning i can't think that this
committee has have ever heard
circumstances that are
better when it comes to being very
special and unique this is a
contribution to our national critical
uh power infrastructure
and that alone
would be
more than sufficient for me
and then we have the discussion
about gasified boilers versus batteries
and and carbon neutrality i think you
almost don't need to bother with that
discussion nowadays so chairman i i feel
so passionately about this i'm i'm happy
to move it at this at this moment in
time with the conditions as outlined in
the report and i would invite someone to
second me on this one thank you
thank you
counselor mrs christie mason
i'm assuming this is working is it have
you got a little green light at the back
i'm told so i have no idea
um
i i just wanted some clarification from
the officers uh please
on certain points could they
show again the relationship of the road
to the area
okay thank you i think i get it from
there and could they on the
more defined map show the area of flood
risk that's referred to in the report
what page are you referring to please
let's say there's an area of flood risk
3 where the um access is going through
and that it will have a knock-on effect
for other areas
crudely
7.1
thank you
any officer yep
sorry
sorry chairman um we're lucky we've got
the author of the report with us if
katie would be able to point out to me
the area of flood risk please
the extent of the area flood risk
i understand it's literally that area of
the junction
okay thank you and
last but not least
um i haven't seen
or if i have i've missed it
any reference to the height of these
storage containers in relation to the
approved plan is it possible to give
that information
i'm not talking about the land that's
covered but the heights in relation to
the approved plan
in other words which is the highest and
by how much
oh there's a
substantial difference chairman these
are
i can't quite read that but i think we
took 2.8 meters or so they're like
container boxes
okay
now if we can go to the cross section we
had there of the gasified ones
um they are similar but i think higher
but they also have two chimneys on
so yeah if we can that's it
um
members with better eyes than me may be
able to work that out but
the the mark the chimney top is 15
meters but i'm not sure where the bulk
is but i'm pretty sure that's a lot
higher than the three meters or so other
batteries that you're looking at tonight
maybe you can
compare
compare the battery that was in the
previous shot
um
the the pen we have with it that's it
i imagine the batteries are probably
about this height
and you see the apparatus in the gas
burners was a far more substantial piece
thank you that that's more than that i
can't tell you the difference in height
can i just kind of i think the visual
difference means the visual impact would
be less less councillor mason can i just
come in on 7.12 page item three the
facility would comprise of 108
single-story steel cabins coming is
known as e-houses the e-houses would
have a depth of 12 meters a width of 2.4
meters and a height of 2.9 meters yes
but that doesn't say in relation to the
gas which no no but so that does tell
you the thing
thank you um if we're going to be timed
madame chairman we're all our time for
five minutes right if we're going to be
timed perhaps you could do the normal
convention and give us the one minute
warning yes certainly happens but i
don't think that happened with
councillor stanley which is why he was
probably a little perplexed
right i certainly support in principle
the capture and storage of energy
uh that would otherwise be lost or
unutilized and acknowledge the
importance of this under the national
policy statement for energy under the
mpf
and that this is considered a material
planning consideration that must be
taken into account in the determination
of a planning application
protection of the green belt also needs
to be acknowledged in relation to the
framework
there is a general consumption against
inappropriate development within the
green belt
and development should not be approved
except in very special circumstances
inappropriate development is by
definition harmful to the green belt
and we must also give substantial weight
to that
the officer report states that the
current proposal is considered to amount
to inappropriate development
but they consider the harm to the green
belt outweighed by the benefits although
this is of course subjective
the report states that the um access
rate is through a flabber area but i
think that the officer has demonstrated
that that is not
an issue
the concern i do have one minute mrs
mason thank you the environment
agency have said they will only be
satisfied if we are satisfied
i would have expected a more
certain and unqualified agreement and
not one that puts the responsibility of
the flooding assessment onto this
authority
thank you thank you very much
council
you need a microphone
apparently it's on hopefully it is um
i'll be brief i'm not sure who managed
to second that first um
i might have done i might not often i
don't know um
i i hope council smith's words i think
at the moment
um special circumstances do exist
we're in a a moment of climate climate
breakdown
um this will go towards
reducing the effects of that if we don't
do something like this
the green belt will disappear it'll be
flood flood belt if you like it it will
get worse
so i've got no problem at all in
supporting the motion thank you thank
you council white councillor spurring
could you pass the microphone open and
wipe it please
thank you chairman
uh i didn't really have any great issues
uh regarding the actual
uh
site the
the project itself and until our
colleague here gave a representation
talking about decommissioning
i don't think i'll be around perhaps in
10 or 15 years time but uh
i wasn't over impressed with the uh
should we say dubious how we're going to
do it i think was a bit suspect
i'd like to go on to some of the issues
relating to
the ecological situation i noticed that
one of the ponds might disappear i can't
understand why we can't just create
another one but that's another issue
we were talking about putting in new
trees and hedgerows and then further
down it says but of course if there's
any changes these could disappear
i think we need to get something sorted
out there
um
and again
we we seem to be yeah i under i fully
endorse the need for this but i don't
think you know we've got to make sure
that issues
do get
monitored
who's going to monitor the flood
scenario i said it says by
can be asked by the local authority i
think we should have more than just be
asked we should have a regular
system whereby
reported to the
to our officers on a yearly basis
not that we just have to ask for it
thank you jim thank you
um a question for
my strengths can we ask for a condition
to people on this that trees are planted
chairman i was
trying to look to the recommendation we
could put a landscaping condition on
rather than just limit it to tree
planting
landscaping per se is far more
beneficial it can involve mounding
there is
if i recall
wildflower meadows and things that
obviously the trees could enhance and
there is i think a tree buffer
if i'm right
if i'm wrong katie on this side here
but
we could we could better that with
having a specific condition that asked
the applicants to um submit species i
think there is a landscaping plan is
there can we
um have a look at that where i think the
applicant has already preempted your
concerns
and set out a landscaping scheme
so you could condition
that i'm told there is a condition that
uh
casualty of not having written these
reports chairman's right um
condition for that's not
yes there is a condition my mistake that
asks um that landscaping be undertaken
the development you're undertaking
according to the landscape it's going to
be approved by the authority but there
is a scheme you see before you where the
applicant has
set out
now you could condition that or as we're
suggesting ask for it to be resubmitted
but bettered
i've just been pointed out i do
planning apologize so it is there
right members
we've had a motion for the table and
seconded all in favor please of this
proposal thank you
i've just been advised councillor
stanley would like to speak again
thank you very much
yes thank you chairman um i would like
to point out also having
which i didn't finish my
briefing to you
yes i know
um
i was going to ask at the same time
uh
is there
a noise factor and also how much
disturbance to the wildlife in that area
i'm told
there are skylarks there
nesting
not nesting at the moment because they
wouldn't be there but there are skylines
nesting and i would like to know that as
from council experience observation
that um
there will be
sufficient
uh material there in the way of trees or
shrubs or whatever and also ponds
so if we if there
if that is the condition on what you're
speaking of
then yes thank you very much it's
already there i did apologize i've
missed it on 7.1
18 that the item four there is a
landscaping
so if you look on your note on your
documents there is also already a
landscaping and i actually miss the
paragraph so i do apologize for that
right members
thank you thank you all right members
we've had a motion it's been seconded
all for uh in favor of approval please
put your hands up and that's on your
account
all against
any obsessions
that
so it's 12 4
approval one abstention thank you
members
we now go on to item eight
which is michelin's now again have you
read the addendum for this please
members
[Applause]
oh my strengths it's you again
very popular tonight
we can't hear you yeah so i can't work
out my red and greens um
thank you chairman
please speak up
yeah ask and speak up yeah i'm good at
that um
this application
is the uh was deferred at the meeting of
the 23rd of september to enable members
to visit the site specifically
it concerns the area that you see the
greater part of those lines
on that site there and members saw at
the site visit that this part is under
construction which by itself doesn't
concern you tonight but just to help you
get your bearings
if we can jump to 02 please
the issue
the deal breaker before us is the
council's application sorry allocation
of a gypsy site
which is in your allocations plan it's a
policy
uh to be achieved and it's part of the
greater site that we see
here
so the site has a mixed allocation
overall partly mostly for industrial but
also for
the gypsy and traveller site if we could
jump to o3 please
members saw at the site visit this is a
computer generated image a 3d view which
nicely shows the context
the development that's currently under
construction nearly finished that we saw
at the site there
the application that concerns you
tonight is for this larger building at
the back
[Music]
you'll see from the report that officers
are content with all the other aspects
other than the issue about the conflict
with the development plan which i'm
going to labor on tonight
and my colleague katie rogers went
through in detail previously when you
deferred the item if we could just hover
on though four plan please
most of the site as you'll see in the
material that you've seen benefits from
outline planning permission this is the
layout plan that accompanied what we
called a hybrid application because it
comprised of outline
for the part of the site that concerns
you tonight with the exception this area
here but in detail what they're building
or nearly finished at the front here
but you'll note that the area of the
allocation for the gypsy site
was undeveloped not part of
the outline permission granted and if we
could just jump to o5 please
you'll see that in that outline
application that you considered the
applicants at that time indicated with
these large arrows the principle of
access to serve the
gypsy site allocation
it was an indicative plan
but it shows in my view
a degree of intent
if we could jump to 06 please this is
the application that's now before you
this is
the balance of the site the gypsy site
allocation is in this part of the
layout the site that's under
construction is this part off plan as it
as we might say but you're looking at
the large blue shaded building there
that is for consideration and was
deferred
last time
i'd ask members to note that it's a full
application in its own right it doesn't
form part of reserve matters to the
previous outline the outline is relevant
for the way that the site is being
developed but this is a standalone
application
in its own right if we could tow 207
please
in decision making
the
um this is the site as a whole this is
how it would be in its entirety if
if planning approval was granted but in
planning decision making the development
plan allocation the gypsy site
allocation the industrial application
for the rest of the site that carries in
planning substantial weight
the allocations have been subject to
testing through a government inspector
holding a public inquiry through
objections through publicity going
through drafts to get to the point that
the
plan is adopted and by yourselves and
becomes an allocation that we work to
and in the balanced terms it has
substantial weight it's very very
weighty so your starting point
is that your
allocation policies said that that site
should be available for
gypsies and travelers
and the inspector in dealing with a
local plan that might have been some
time now
but found that there was no objection to
that allocation in terms of any
suitability it got passed through any
tests any concerns that they had at that
time
there has been a history of complicated
ownership i won't go into the details
because that would be unfair on the
person's involved but members will
recall that there was prosecutions the
site ownership changed to the family the
family then sold it to i believe the
current applicants but i may be wrong on
that but what i'm trying to demonstrate
is
the
earlier owner wasn't exactly pleased
with the council taking action with him
at the time hardly somebody would go
into partnership
that
subject to that
different family members took on the
site and that the current
applicants have only been the owners i
think since around three years ago
something like that so there's been
changes in ownership and there's been
other things going on which hasn't
helped bring the site forward
the aspirations of the council for the
site as a whole were also
to relocate the raleigh recycling centre
and a desire to get
other industrial areas such as the royal
industrial state away from the housing
areas and located to these premises now
we realize those aspirations won't be
achieved
now
while some of those uses may take up the
units that are already uh being built
that that's you know a matter for them
paragraph 122 of the national planning
policy framework part of the national
government's uh strategy for planning
does make clear that a count that
accounts for the need for decisions to
reflect changes in demand for land
allocated in development plans
we're informed by land availability
studies now the applicant has made a
clear case that there's a demand for
their
units officers have no problem with that
but where the local authority considers
there to be no reasonable prospect of an
application coming forward for the use
allocated in this case the gypsy site
the government advises that a plan
application should be reconsidered in a
plan review possibly de-allocated
or in the meantime alternative uses
could be supported and this is the
difference between us and the applicants
officers go one way hence the
recommendation to you the applicant has
got a strong case the other way it's
very much on a fine line
okay
now members will see on the addendum
that there's been extensive material
submitted by the applicants and as
you've all had a chance to read it i
don't propose to go through it in detail
i also believe you've been approached
direct
with letters that we have got
copies of and a flyer i believe that was
produced today that repeats some of the
material
so the point being that even up to this
last minute you've had quite a lot of
information from from the applicant
to summarize that
the applicants feel that it will not be
possible for the council to realize the
gypsy site allocation
they're talking from their experience of
the sites that they've so far developed
the d-connect termination the
construction costs etc
they've got a basis there that's in some
of the material
of at least they think 1.3 million it's
not a total amount
comprising site acquisition and
provision for the known costs there are
further potential costs for
decontamination of 0.4 of a million
and plus the need for a substantial
landscape buffer between the gypsy site
and the commercial so the costs would be
quite considerable they're saying that
as loud landowners now now that we're
dealing with these people as the
landowners they would be unwilling
to
give up the site obviously subject to
acquisition
they would want to develop it out so
they would object if you like
that means that the council hand has to
consider compulsory acquisition to
deliver the plan allocation that it is
that it is made
in art
they're saying that because they
wouldn't be likely to give access
notwithstanding what they showed you in
the outline application
that the site will be landlocked so that
you wouldn't be able to achieve access
to deliver the site
[Music]
and they're also saying there's been
lack of interest shown from the
travelling community and bringing the
site forward
they're pointing out that the appeal
inspectors on a number of gypsy site
applications that we've fought has been
critical
of the lack of progress in site delivery
and that
they also have advice from council that
is also set out that you say that says
the council's position
is not is not robust
they have offered because you need to
mitigate the loss of the allocation
they've offered a unilateral undertaking
of the payment of 600 000 pounds 0.6 of
a million
that could be put towards providing an
alternative site should planning
permission be granted
there are benefits that they say should
be taken into account as well
that there would be over 30 000 square
meters of commercial floor space in this
building an average in the construction
stage of about 190 construction jobs and
up to 800 new full-time equivalent jobs
to support the local economy
a post-pandemic boost of somewhere
between 28 million and 56 million per
annum for the local economy and
approximately one million per annum in
business rates that you're asking me to
take into
consideration now officers
say there's a lot in favor of this
scheme we have no problem with the
physical planning sides and there's lots
of merit that we've
just touched on
but then remains in offices view a clear
shortfall in the provision of the unmet
made and demand for gypsy and traveller
sites in the district and if we lost the
allocation whether it can be realized or
not we would be going
in my view somewhat backwards and it's
for members to decide
it's a very fine balance now it's gone
from being heavily in favor of the
development plan so when you take into
account what the applicant is saying
it's coming back up level now for
officers position we think the scales
are just tipped because
as far as we can determine at least at
the time of producing the reports
there is still
perhaps a remote possibility or whatever
that the council might
compulsory acquire the site there's
nothing official we've got no reports to
full council or members or whatever on
which we can rely so we're recommending
a cautious approach
that in the moment in time
from what we know so far
the balance means that the application
should be refused on the basis of the
conflict from the development plan for
the reason that's set out in the report
thank you chairman thank you very much
we have one speaker for this um mr tim
rainbird you have as per the others you
have five minutes so
great can you hear me
no you're not are you one excellent
good evening chair and members of the
development committee i am tim rainbird
the agent speaking on behalf of the
applicant and the landowner of michigan
farm star uk radio popco limited
first would like to thank members for
attending the site visit on saturday the
15th of october i hope that was useful
to see the allocated employment site
alongside the gypsy in travel allocation
and aid you in reaching what we hope
will be a positive decision on this full
planning application this evening
i would also like to thank officers for
the addendum report which was published
yesterday afternoon
as before your officers are recommending
refusal on a single ground namely a
departure from your development plan by
way of the loss of gypsy and traveller
site allocation
officers are recommending refusal on the
basis they believe there to be a
reasonable prospect of the gt1
allocation coming forward
with an application for gypsy and travel
accommodation
namely through the compulsory purchase
of the land by the council
perhaps most significantly your office's
addendum explicitly states that if the
leader and the cabinet decided not to
pursue the compulsory purchase of the
gypsian traveler site officers would be
recommending this application for
approval
the office's addendum also recognises
that the evidence needed to support the
reasonable prospect test is very limited
the following significant weaknesses are
acknowledged
no substantive work has been undertaken
to inform the cpo process
nothing has been progressed but beyond
initial request back in march
there is no defined time frame setting
out the intended progression of
compulsory purchase of the land this has
been requested by officers since august
and has not yet been provided
officers also recognize that the cpo
process is complicated and it is
possible that the council will not
decide to pursue this course of action
members will also be aware that the
prospect of a cpo was set out in the
allocations plan some eight years ago in
that eight years no programme or
proposal has come forward to cpo the
allocated land at michelin farm
all of these facts would suggest that
there is a real prospect that the cpo
will never materialize and that a
possibility or as you've heard
this evening a remote chance of this
happening is simply not sufficient
in this instance to warrant refusal
planning commission
setting to one side the lack of evidence
to demonstrate that the cpo is a
reasonable prospect the allocated
gypsian traveler site has clear
suitability and deliverability issues
as your officers have summarised this
evening
we believe that the land will be an
inappropriate location for new homes
either for the traveling or settled
communities the site is surrounded by
major roads the east coast mainline and
shadowed by high voltage power cable
pilots
the site has no access
the site is heavily contaminated and has
no gas electricity or sewerage
connections
resolving these issues is likely to cost
the council more than 1.75 million
pounds if a cpo is to come forward
the officer's addendum also confirms
that the costs associated with the
delivery of the site is significant
and that the council do not have
evidence to demonstrate that all the
necessary resources are available to
deliver the project
these deliverability and suitability
issues have been raised as you've heard
by inspectors when determining other
appeals for similar accommodation in the
district
and the council has been criticized for
the reliance upon the michelin farm
allocation because it doesn't provide
private pitches
or a choice of sites to meet the needs
of the community and as a consequence
the policy approach does conflict with
national policy
recognizing the council's urgent and
pressing need for the gypsy and travel
accommodation across the district the
applicant has increased the section 106
contribution to 600 000 pounds
and it is expected that contribution
will be used to deliver alternative
sites which also avoids having to pursue
an extremely costly and uncertain cpo
process
one minute thank you the opportunity
before you this evening is therefore
both significant and compelling at the
heart of the proposals lies an
undeniable boost to the local economy as
you've heard
800 full-time equivalent jobs a million
pounds in business rates and 16 million
pounds of direct investment through
construction
the application responds to strong
market demand it will deliver 30 000
square meters of modern warehousing and
presents a unique opportunity for the
district
turning down this application
represents a significant reputation of
financial risk to the council by saying
no to jobs
and investment because of a gypsy and
traveller's site in the wrong location
may never come forward i therefore urge
you to support this planning application
with our increased section 106 offer
which will genuinely assist in meeting
the district's needs for gypsy and
traveller accommodation
thank you thank you very much
visiting
councillors
counselor simon woodson i hope would you
like to speak please
thank you madam chairman and members i
visited this site a few weeks ago in the
company of the assistant director of
planning and the chief executive officer
firstly i'd like to acknowledge the
development and the work that has been
done to tidy up what was an untidy site
dreadfully contaminated following a
major fire
the scheme where phase one is now at an
advanced stage will provide significant
economic
regeneration and employment
opportunities for the benefit of our
community and i welcome that
having said that we cannot overlook the
fact that part of the land whilst in the
current ownership of the developer is
designated under the local plan as a
gypsy and traveler site and as an
authority i believe we have a duty to
deliver that
to a large extent there has been a very
little engagement with rochford district
council by the developer on how to work
together to meet these obligations
and madam chairman if i may read out an
email that i wrote following a
presentation to
set members of the executive earlier
this year on the 1st of march and i
would like to place this on record dear
marcus i referred to our meeting earlier
today with the developers from
michelin's farm the site was bought by
the current owners in the full knowledge
that there was an allocation for a gypsy
and traveller site and this was probably
reflected in the value
it is clear from our meeting that phase
two planning application is coming
forward very soon which completely
disregards this provision and is seeking
to justify why the allocation is being
ignored for technical reasons and using
appeal precedence which the developers
feel supports their case
now in isolation i believe the proposed
scheme looks excellent there is however
a principle here what is the point of
making allocations and then developers
coming along only to drive a coaching
horse through what is considered a long
established local plan
i think we need to be proactive here and
consider a cpo on the designated land in
order to protect it for its intended
purpose
it is no good as an authority as coming
up with the designated sites for
travellers and then when they are not
developed us taking the flack for them
being accused of not providing for that
sector of our community
so realistically
madam chairman this is a difficult
decision for the committee tonight
but last night
we had a briefing talking about a
designated site within the local plan
and here we are tonight
potentially faced with lifting a site
out of the designated local plan it
would be totally inconsistent for us to
do that
it is pleasing that of late discussions
have been taking place with the
developer
and it is an arbitrary view as to what
value you put on a piece of land
my own preference would have been for
the developer at the outset to work with
us in deliver delivering the intended
purpose the reason if i may say that the
developer points to the fact that there
is no access is because the app the
developer has not provided for any
access so it is as simple as that the
scheme has been worked on from the
outset would have provided for
egress
so
it is for the committee to consider
whether we deal with a point of
principle here
should a multi-million pound developer
be allowed to buy their way out of a
scheme for intended purpose
or should they be held to work with
rochford district council on delivering
a scheme that was intended as a gypsy
and traveller site
thank you madam chairman thank you
members thank you
councillor
have you anything you would like to say
councillor newport
i might will be coming to you
well again you'll have five minutes
thank you chairman
and members
many of you will know that the issue of
delivering this particular traveler site
in our
land allocation
has gone on for far too long and i
support the leader councillor wootton
in his comments
we should not bow to the pressures put
on the committee by
the developer at risk of appeal
we have a duty to all of our residents
both settled and the traveler community
there is a legal obligation by this
council
to bring forward a traveler's site we
have been criticized heavily by a
planning inspector
for not doing this
the questions that i would have
and this is a question both for
our council and officers
is that i note from the report that
neither essex county council or the
traveler unit has a capital budget to
bring the site forward
so in order to strengthen our case
against a possible appeal
i would like to see the council commit
to a budget to bring forward our
traveler's site
what would
the legal ramifications
to the council be
of not bringing forward this allocated
site and the provision
of this gypsy and traveller site as the
law dictates
it is a fine line
yes there are jobs on the line but we're
also told that there are 1.1 million
vacancies in the uk
so i'd just like you to bear that in
mind also when making the decision thank
um
you
the wall counsellor is councillor norman
yes that's you sir
thank you chairman
ringing in my ears here
um
i just want to say that i was one of
those who went on the site visit and i
found that very informative and it was
it was worthwhile um i have to support
what our leaders
but when i was over there people keep
talking about entry we we entered by a
site entrance at the side
um which literally adjoined the car
parking where we were which literally
had joined this site and and i cannot
see why that can't be why we have to go
through all the yard and everything else
when you could come in through what is
now currently a site entrance
near the back of that house
and come straight into the gypsy site so
um i personally
i was concerned i did have a lot of
thoughts about it you know on the
balance of what it stand up to and
appeal etc etc but uh i have to say that
everything i've heard so far i have to
support and it is in a local plan so
um i must say that i
personally moved to
accept
the recommendation from the planning
and we've got second to uh mr councillor
mrs mason
uh mrs mason
thank you is this one
i can hear you
wipe it down please
right thank you madam chairman in my
view
this is a simple matter of principle
and the application is unfortunately
premature and in my views opportunist my
understanding is that the site in the
local plan remains an allocated site
and it is not usual for that site to be
removed from the allocation
even in a new local plan
unless it is established with strong and
irrefutable evidence that the site is
not deliverable
if it was established that the site was
no longer viable it would then be
required to be reassessed and it would
be judged on either the requirements of
the new local plan
or on its merits
nevertheless at this point in time the
site is still considered rdc's main
and only
allocated site for gypsy and travelers
in our local plan
the financial information should not
sway or
determine
the planning process
and regardless of the financial
incentives to do otherwise
the council has a moral and legal
obligation to provide suitable
accommodation for gypsy and travellers
in our area
this is the only site that has been
identified as suitable
however in this case the site in
question is under investigation by the
council
for compulsory purchase
in order to implement the allocation of
the local plan
it is to be regretted that the local
plan having been adopted in december
2011 that the council has only recently
undertaken this investigation
and the delay in providing a time frame
for determination has not facilitated
clarity
that said
i totally support the officer's
recommendation for refusal on the
grounds that the application is contrary
to our adopted plan
and that the council is actively
investigating the viability of pursuing
the compulsory purchase of the
difficulty and traveller site allocation
in order to implement its local plan and
i certainly second that i would also
like to
add if kelsey lawman is um
agreeable and if it's agreeable to the
chair that we recommend that a budget is
put aside to um
for this i'm not sure if it's
appropriate in this committee
no i thought it wouldn't be but i was
trying
thank you
so i i second the officer's
recommendation for refusal for clarity
thank you thank you councilman mason um
councillor smith uh thank you i were
talking to the recommendation but just
uh depending on which way it goes just a
couple of questions to know to know have
we got
a full range of conditions in place
if we do end up talking to approval and
secondly
the 600k that you that was mentioned
um
have we got that formally in writing
because i do understand it was a a late
late change
um to the to the motion that's before us
to me this revolves around the council's
ability
to deliver the compulsory purchase
i don't underestimate the scale of the
challenge in doing that
the
location of the site
the potential
for lack of cooperation
with the
current developer and the need to
challenge and
work out the various arrangements
which will involve legal representation
the scale of the contamination that is
on the site
is also
a great concern because it is unknown it
is not just tires that it was quite
clear to see on site that
there's a wide range of things
and balancing that
against the
economic loss to the district
potentially direct employment
and
the
the the
benefit to the council from increased
business rates
then as a council ourselves
we do have to consider our ability to
deliver a compulsory purchase
we have reserves as everyone knows that
they are earmarked for a wide variety of
issues and this would be a new burden on
the council
and
in assessing the delivery of
deliverability of the site i think that
is a
relevant relevant point excuse me madam
chairman i don't think that's talking to
the um
motion on the table the
the
other two items that
are
under consideration for deliverability
are
the
the support that we've had from the
essex
gypsy and traveller unit they they might
not have a budget but we've had this
site allocated for quite some time
and
i don't think they've been nudging us
too hard on the delivery element of it
uh and and then finally i think i do
have to just express
my my concern with
the way in which the developer has gone
about um doing this it's
as a as an experienced developer i i
think they they could have gone about
this in a a much more collaborative way
i'm not
i'm not
i'm not swayed one way or the other i'm
i'm i'm on the fence
i will normally always go with the
office of recommendation because it is a
professional point of view but i'm
wanting to hear
the the comments of other members before
i
make my mind up as to which way i'll
raise my hand thank you
thank you council smith council hawaii
cancer stanley at the beginning i did
ask every member to wipe
the mics while you're passing forward
because of um because of the kovid
situation that we still have so that's
what i was asking and everyone in front
of them we've got a hand sanitizer
and wipes okay it's just to keep you
safe
and other members thank you thank you
councillor i got a gold star do i
i'll be brief
um
there's clearly a real demand for a
traveller site within the district it's
evidenced by the ad hoc applications
that have taken place over the years
where we have no defense to them
and this is because we failed to provide
a traveller's site
i think it's important we do not lose
this site it's designated as a proposed
traveler site in our local plan
and it will meet our commitment to the
travelling community
um i have to say nothing i've heard
tonight has persuaded
me that this council should deviate from
that pain that plan or the allocation
and i support councilor norman's um
motion for refusal
thank you council stanley
please see you soon
thank you chairman um
it's been
quite a
a discussion coming on from
2011 or whatever 2009 when this was
discussed
and and
the council has
inadvertently left it on the on the back
burner for such a long time
which
i'm
surprised at what we are now endeavoring
to do
from councillor smith's le marx
on the
cost of
doing the work
and there's no there's no supply of
anything on the site nothing at all so
all that's got to go in in the way of
sewage and what have you
there is an awful awful lot to do and i
have to say that with remarks from
councillor newport in the way of
have we got allocation funds for that
no we haven't
yes we have got reserves but we don't
know what's going to happen in the
future
it's going to be more than what i think
the
developer has estimated
i do believe that you know by the time
we get round to doing it maybe in five
years time even if we do a cpo order
that will only last for six years
with the with the uh regulation that's
applied with that
and it will come back to us again and
again
and we've got to make the decision we've
got to make the decision and it's a fine
decision we are going to make i mean i'm
on the fence as well
with
it's
touch and go um and i at the moment
with the way
the that we are planning for the future
for housing and people coming into the
district and what have you we need the
employment as well so it is it is
something which we've got to weigh up as
a council it's not just this committee
it's everybody we work for
the committee makes the decision but
there is a lot to consider thank you
very much thank you we have a motion on
the table from sir lorman
oh sorry councillor foster you would
you need to put your hand up sir
and council western
no after councilor possibly again
um thank you chairman um i find myself
sitting on the same pence as
a couple of other councillors
um absolutely agree with the need
um i understand the cpo and that may be
an expensive process um i'm not i'm not
seeing anything that tells us where the
budget for actually developing it would
come from what i've read says nobody's
got any budget for it
and
given that is there a reasonable
prospect of an application being made
for the site to become
a traveller site
thank you very much councillor weston
have you a mic anywhere now don't look
at me like that please
thank you chairman i think i
most of the members have said really
what i was going to say i think i have
to agree with quite a few of them dances
on the fence as well i find it very hard
and difficult that we've had this
allocation it's only an allocation for
egyptian traverse site and it's been
sitting there for quite a few years
you've got a company that owns a site
that wants to that wants to fulfill it
by hopefully
making
more
jobs
etcetera for the our community and
bringing money into you know into
rochford so again i'm very much sitting
on the site on the sidelines or sitting
on the fence and i'm going to find it
very very difficult to
to where i'm putting my vote tonight
thank you thank you very much
that counts
council spurring
thank you chairman
um i don't find myself sitting on the
fence at all
i
cannot
condone
some of the things that have gone on in
the past and all the rest of it at the
long and short of it is this is an
allocated site
and potentially my my personal view is
if we don't follow this through we will
be opening up a floodgate in years to
come where other allocated sites are
then using this
as a criteria of why we shouldn't
conform with what we've already agreed
is an allocated site this is an
allocated site for gypsy and travellers
and i think we should do our utmost to
see it through thank you chairman thank
you very much
does any other member require to speak
no show of hands so we've had a motion
to refuse it
so can i have
a show of hands for refusal please
yes of course
you can take your hands down members
can i have a
show of hands for
approval
refusal approval
sorry
against refusal get the right wording
so it will be recorded as an abstention
so the application is refused members
and do we know the numbers please honey
four extensions nine refusals thank you
members thank you very much for a good
debate tonight
and i closed the meeting at
nine
something uh eight fifty eight fifty
three thank you